there has been a Resurgence of interest
in kabalah in the last couple of decades
and kabalah is taught in various places
around the world sometimes deeply
connected to traditional Judaism
sometimes with a more Universalist and
maybe even New Age interpretation we've
seen several celebrities show interest
in kabala and bring it to a wider
audience such as perhaps most notably
Madonna at the same time kism continues
to be one of the most prominent
movements within Judaism embodying
Traditions that are centuries old in
other words while Jewish iism has
evolved over the centuries and taken on
many different forms it remains a very
significant and important part of one of
the most significant and largest
religions in the world